and on the subject of tender care and
kindness my thoughts
is our special series kindness 101 with
one of my favorite storytellers steve
hartman we know steve from his on the
road series won a lot of emmys for that
it's a cbs evening news and sunday
morning series now he shares stories
with us that are built around themes of
kindness and character
and the people who have mastered those
qualities they exist it's a topic that
is a great
discussion starter for you and your kids
but uh we are also quite confident as
the oscars reminded us last night that
there are adults who could learn a thing
or two from steve hartman as well
today's lesson is optimism steve and his
kids tell us about a little girl and the
horse that she always knew could be a
champion
good morning i'm here with my daughter
merrill hi everyone and we have a good
feeling about this class because it's
about optimism and i see you have a
glass there that is half empty
no it's half full
interesting
and i think that's inching us closer to
our definition let's go over to emmett
at the dictionary desk optimism is to
look on the better or brighter side of
things yeah i kind of look at optimism
as a superpower
a way to alter the course of future
events and you know how that happens
you
decide how you want to look at them
that's right so let's turn now to my
library of stories past for a real-life
example of the unbelievable power of
positive thinking
for as long as her parents can remember
briana carsey has had this crazy dream
she has always wanted a brewed mare a
mommy horse that would give birth to a
baby horse that would grow up to become
a racing champion this was a fairy tale
for her from day one
we put it off for five years almost
because we don't have a farm it sounds
expensive yeah why don't you say no
well as she'll tell you she has me
wrapped around her finger
her foal and ohio standard bread was
born in the spring of 2013. she named it
mjb got faith mjb for the initials of
the kids in her family and got faith for
the faith she instantly had in him
i really loved him
from the beginning
he's super soft too
but that quick bond posed a real problem
for this pushover dad bud see for
whatever reason brian thought once he
explained to his daughter that her horse
could never race that it was a runt from
poor breeding stock she would just agree
to sell it
but obviously not
she's like there's no price daddy
so i'm talking to my wife it's like you
know we really got ourselves in a mess
here yeah i don't know how we're gonna
get out of this
so we stake him to the races this horse
that doesn't belong in the races the
horse that i thought we should have
gotten rid of already
brian was stuck committed to boarding
and training this long shot to end all
long shots
and this is not a wealthy family brian
runs a small logistics company and ohio
racing which is harness style racing is
a 900 million dollar a year industry i
want to see him go fast mjb got faith
was so slow he barely even qualified to
compete
but then somehow someway
won his first race
one his second race his third and his
fourth qualifying him for the state
championship
i said baby if you finish third
you should be so thankful she goes daddy
if he finishes last
i'm going to be thankful
but he's going to win
and so it was
that this little horse with no pedigree
this pet with no reason for being here
beyond the blind faith of a little girl
[Applause]
won an ohio sire steaks championship
she said dad i told you you got to have
faith
brianna took home a hundred thousand
dollars that day she has already given
away half of it to charity and as for
the other half she plans to use that
money as a down payment on a farm
i just want to have a farm and be able
to go walk out my back door and see him
and that's her plan for happily ever
after just a girl her horse and knowing
her father dad can we please get a cat
no
probably a cat
too
i want to know if i got a cat i kind of
do too let's find out how are you guys
good how are you we're good did you get
the cat i didn't i get the cat
i got a puppy instead though oh
how is mjb and
where is mjb now he's doing good he's
retired now so he's living his best life
in a field so you have the land
yes and as i recall you got another
horse
and named it steve hartman
we did that's steve hartman the early
trailer how did that horse do he raced
four times i believe it was ever get
last place
uh yes
[Music]
two out of the four races he was last
place great not good we have to find a
steve hartman too yeah well i don't know
if you want to push your luck you're not
being very optimistic
you're understanding like me
i don't want that
so i think we all know who was the
optimist in that story and who was the
pessimist sure
i was just curious did that whole
experience change you in any way yes it
honestly has this process it truly has
changed me to
believe things are possible and the
glass is always half full not half empty
and if you put your mind to it you work
hard be dedicated you can do anything
you want
that's beautiful okay thank you so much
for joining us you guys i appreciate you
guys thank you so there's your proof
that the future is how you see it
we'll see you next time until then stay
kind
[Music]
thank you
that's one of my favorite parts when
meryl goes until then stay kind i agree
with you meryl stay kind but i love the
story where when she said to her dad dad
if he comes in last i would be happy
with that but he's going to come in
first that's what you call optimism she
knew rihanna knew what we
we should try to do as adults is retain
that kid-like sense of optimism yes way
past childhood because that is how you
get through things i've always believed
that and brianna is living proof 100 000
cash prize for that horse's win is
pretty nice not too shabby either i'm
very much identifying with the fathers
and steve's uh pieces can we have a cat
no
i thought the answer was going to be
that they did get a cat i found the
problem but he held the line on the cat
he lost on the horse and then he held it
on the cat all right i would have picked
the horse okay you can find all the
kindness 101 episodes at our website
cbsnews.com
kindness 101 and you can also find them
on our facebook page